foreign
[Music]
she's amazing
love the green stockings
you're Lizzy right I can't figure out
what class this is
but I really want to join it
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
without hot water my show is open on
Friday I'll be free to deal with it
after that I have a show too you know
you're not the only one with a deadline
I know but I have two shows which is
insane
hey give me a push
foreign
you should make more like this I'm
enjoying my retirement I get up I do a
little of this a little of that and
before you know it it's time to watch TV
again that sounds terrible
[Music]
what's going on
I'm making a piece it's a very major
piece
very major he's a genius he was always
incredibly creative a lot of people are
creative I saw some of y'alls work at a
studio yesterday wow it just gives me
such a lift
pretty amazing
when's my hot water coming back on I'm
on it easy on the cheese it's for
everyone I don't want to run out
creatures out on the table you'll soon
put keys out on the table if you don't
want people to eat it
you know I'm sick of not having hot
water Joe it's such a total drag and
such a shitty thing to do to a person
I'm sick of it
have a great night
they're not supposed to have any cheese
[Music]